this is quasiquartang's resignation
you have asked me to stand aside as your
Chancellor I have accepted this is
quasiquartang's letter to Liz trust the
Prime Minister when you ask me to serve
as your Chancellor I did so in full
knowledge that the situation we faced
was incredibly difficult with Rising
Global interest rates and energy prices
however your vision of optimism growth
and change was right quasiquartang goes
on to say as I have said many times in
the past weeks following the status quo
was simply not an option for too long
this country has been dragged down by
low growth weights and high taxation
that must still change if the country is
to succeed the former Chancellor goes on
to say the economic environment has
changed rapidly since we set out the
growth plan on the 23rd of September in
response together with the bank of
England and excellent officials at the
treasury we have responded to those
events and I commend my officials for
their dedication he then says it's
important now we move forward to
emphasize your government's commitment
to fiscal discipline the medium term
fiscal plan is crucial to this end and I
look forward to supporting you and my
successor to achieve that from the back
benches and he ends like this we have
been colleagues and friends for many
years in that time I have seen your
dedication and determination I believe
your vision is the right one it has been
an honor to serve as your first
Chancellor your success is this
country's success and I wish you well
you can see it on your screen now I just
read out the full thing